a golden knights themed event happening  at levitt middle school today special  olympics students got to brush up on  their street hockey skills in teams of  gold red and black teachers say the goal  is to help integrate both special and  general education students  putting something on locally at our  school was our challenge so making sure  that those two communities know each  other got to know each other  got to  be able to work together and realize  that it doesn't matter who you are the  we're still students here at levitt and  that was important for us  that is important and teachers say they  really want to continue events like this  at the school so students can foster  those important friendships early on not  to mention getting outside getting a  little vitamin d having fun playing some  hockey  we love it